[Music]
almost two full minutes of regurgitating
stuff we already know
not a baby bird marvel i can chew my own
plot food okay
the global repatriation council knows
that for many
it wasn't that easy wait it wasn't that
easy
last time i said the blip was a bad idea
someone reminded me that hulk said he
wanted everyone to return safely
certainly took into account their
psychological health as well right
i know i'm beating a dead pedantic horse
here go figure but all i'm trying to say
is that marvel has still not wrestled
with the moral ambiguity of returning
half the population
after being mourned as lost for five
years
i'm gonna send them for it every chance
i get reset
restore rebuild why go with rebuild when
restructure is right there and would
keep the res going
this is why everyone hates you marvel
can anyone explain to me why cap's
helmet is designed to push his ears out
like this
and it's not the actor because i had the
same thought even when there was a chris
wearing it
i'm just saying there are so many better
options in this captain alfred
america design do you know who i am an
ever-increasing caricature of american
entitlement that's bordering on parody
and starting to hinder my ability to buy
into the story
am i close in case you confused it with
berlin take my breath away
that time wasn't exactly a picnic this
saying
picnics are not easy and generally suck
there's wind and critters in bumpy
seeding and aunt jerry's about five hard
lemonades into a rant on border control
you know honestly when something is
terrible
it should be called a picnic what are
you talking about you want to break
zemo out of jail the better question is
why are you only talking about it now
what part of falcon's personality makes
you think he wouldn't have forced a
conversation about what happened in
there immediately
especially considering there's time for
an entire jailbreak sometime before we
get to this conversation
he is crazy but he still has a code yeah
and i've been on the wrong side of that
code buck and so have you
this show is desperately trying to use
this sam bucky conversation to give us a
valid reason bucky would go all
finding zemo and break him out of jail
but it's clearly only because the plot
needs it to happen
which honestly is happening a lot on
this show what's the book you're reading
machiavelli i've watched this prison
break scene several thousand times now
and i still can't figure out what's
supposed to have happened here
bucky asks him what he's reading as if
he's the one to put the key card in the
book but
how and when zemos apparently already
been reading the book so
why hasn't he seen it before and then
they just happened to walk bucky through
gen pop during chess time and completely
miss him tossing this note to one of the
local grand masters
speaking of the note when did he have
time to write it and with what and how
did he know there would be a situation
where just two guys are sitting at a
table
wouldn't that he will kill you tonight
note have been confusing if he had to
drop it at a table with several inmates
and why does mobby fisher here even
believe this random note from an
absolute random stranger then the escape
completely yada yada's how zemo got
outside the building preferring just to
show him use his card on a couple
interior doors as if he somehow knew
exactly where he was going
i mean i suppose i could have just
thrown a this works on this whole escape
but then i wouldn't have gotten to use
the moppy fisher joke and
no one keeps me from my name puns no one
so all this time you've been rich
apparently so it's a good thing too
because we need a jet for any of this to
work
who cares that his asset should have
been seized marvel's got a marvel i
guess
he's out of line but he's right tv sends
defenders
james you will have to become someone
you claim is gone
is it santa claus oh please tell me it's
santa claus playing soccer in enclosed
spaces
or really at all hell he does look like
me though convenient doppelgangers
conventional gangers
[Music]
this opening street cry montage fast and
furious is on for some time
also do you want broken ankles because
this is how you get broken
ankles i love these character has to eat
or drink something disgusting to prove
they aren't an outsider cliche
a power broker really my response from
the future when someone tells me this is
their favorite episode of the show
somehow makes it into the script sure
in the grimiest crimiest underbelly bar
in this hive of scum and villainy people
are still whipping out their phones to
record this kerfuffle
this would be one of the most violent
group of cameraverse people in history
anyone trying to snag some social media
clout down here would basically be
trading their lives for
likes onto basebook or whatever site
obvious criminal stereotypes use for
social media these days
the breadcrumbs are gonna for free what
the bakery is gonna cost you baron
using carbohydrates for evil instead of
good aside from the overall stupidity of
leaving his phone on vibrate
sam lets this phone rumble for several
seconds before he's then asked to answer
it on speaker
why didn't just reject that call
immediately also i'm throwing in a sin
for sarah
and anyone else who calls someone
without texting first this is 2021 sarah
show some respect for mobile protocol
also also i'm not sure which i'm more
impressed with that you're managing to
get two full bars of service down in
this dungeon or that you took the time
to ask someone here for the wi-fi
password
kill them deus ex power broken uh x
sharina x bothana running these heels
calling these heels was is big
difference
i mean maybe but if someone said i was a
serial killer or i
am a serial killer the difference starts
to shrink a bit doesn't it
sharon we need your help stating the
obvious what's going on sharon
what's going on is that sharon has a
rack of clothing that will perfectly fit
you
that's twice in one day that sam has had
a perfectly tailored outfit change
without having to resort to
gym shorts and an old ratty t-shirt that
says orgasm donor on the front
crowds and yes i would have seen this
before the pandemic ii there's just more
people on my side now
also we spend so much time on this party
montage that i'm beginning to think this
episode is 30 establishing montages
16 actual plot and 54 trying to justify
all these people being willing to work
with
[ __ ] zemo having a secret entrance
that is unlocked and can be opened with
a simple push
you know who he is right this is baron
zemo
i know you've heard of him too right of
course because every single person in
this entire universe is familiar with
every single player in these movies i'm
just saying 90 of america couldn't even
tell you who eugene goodman is and that
dude is about as close as we get to a
superhero on this planet
so excuse me if i'm doubtful every
bounty hunter in the city is here we
gotta go
seeing does not contain a boba fett also
i get that every bounty hunter is after
you but how did any of them know you
were here right now
and why would they share that info with
anyone else not my pig not my farm
charlotte's web deniers
this guy waits until such the perfect
moment to block convenience's rocket
launcher they might as well have left
the director in the shot screaming
action
it's an every action movie falcon
stressed would be excellent at tv since
but also every time these two fight i
get lethal weapon vibes and honestly
their chemistry is so good i'm somehow
not hating it
no i've watched enough mythbusters to
know you can't just know where to shoot
a pipe so it explodes like that no
matter how skilled you are
you think you can do these things but
you just can't zemo
also now all of a sudden zemo has gone
from an intellectual manipulator with an
avengers grudge to a
wealthy vigilante wearing a mask with
dead-eye aiming skills and incredible
fighting prowess
since when did zemo turn into the mcu's
version of batman
so they just happen to pick an empty
open shipping container that somehow
leads to a magical escape car
did you see a mr tumnus in there as well
were you offered some turkish delight on
your way through
guess i won't be needing this anymore if
we get the job done do you really think
they're gonna sweat us on the how
putting the ends before the means and
what i mean by that is that this show is
more concerned about having dramatic
episode ends without worrying about what
any of it actually means
thanks taurus saying a character's name
out loud because it's been so long since
they've actually been in the show that
we've forgotten they exist
i was wondering when you were going to
show up is like a path of camoyobeads
really the best way to do this
anyone could have seen those and pick
them up before bucky did i guess marvel
just wanted to walk on the convenient
side of the street for this one huh
hey yo sorry guys it's it's basically a
disease at this point
and this chateau le blanc 68 is supposed
to be
served slightly chilled this is room
temperature
did you know that we create monthly
exclusive videos for our city club
members bonus outtakes
i don't know peter meth is a hell of a
drug extra sins videos
strange things are afoot at the circle k
and even member chosen sin commentaries
i love this
i love this this kind of of a sin
because it's just
it's so silly pick our next video and
see the exclusives at patreon.com
cinemasins or click the link in the
description below spiderman is not a
parade you do not need to stop traffic
for spanish
[Laughter]
sir that stolen lima bit one of your
prostitutes right in the face
and she says she can't go to hospital
because she's quote
tripping balls you will be sorely missed
you little
bat-faced piece of [ __ ]
i have never well i'll get you in all of
my 23 years
so pirate sanctuary do what you want
cause a pirate is free
you are a pirate snakes
why did it have to be snakes can anybody
tell you that this is the private club
of the satan's helpers
nobody hit me to that dude you have a
real problem now
so leave your weapons and follow my lead
[Music]